wo ist dein leben
ja ich heute morgen vielleicht etwas
früher kommen
warum ist der 22 und ich habe ja kein
problem also am 23
kleiner tipp morgen ist der 22 seines
übermorgen der 23 nein über morgen habe
ich mittags keine termine nur okay aber
denkst du dran vom ersten bis zum
november habe ich nochmal frühdienst
jetzt ja das habe ich auch so wie man
kann unterstellen dass marek hier ist
tarek hallo ja auch am wochenende öffnen
wir morgens um neun und schließen abends
um elf uhr ja heute abend sie möchten
einen tisch reservieren um viertel vor
sieben tut mir leid wir haben leider
erst um viertel vor acht ein tisch frei
am fenster natürlich alles klar
okay wir freuen uns auf sie danke auf
wieder danke dir für deine hilfe
das mache ich gern